it is in every nook and cranny of
academia
a lot of people said exactly what you
were saying well this is just some
esoteric nonsense
that a few bozos and the humanities and
the social sciences are doing absolutely
not
right now most of the granting agencies
that fund
you know research in the natural
sciences in physics and chemistry and
biology and the neurosciences
will require the grant applicants
to submit a what i call a die religion
statement die stands for diversity
inclusion and equity
where you literally have to state right
up front
irrespective of what you're saying what
is it that you've done to
you know promote die principles and what
are you going to do if you were to win
the grant
in promoting thy principles
i'm dave rubin and this is the reuben
report quick reminder everyone to
subscribe to our youtube channel and
then re-subscribe when the subscribe
gremlins unsubscribe you
and joining us today is an evolutionary
behavioral scientist
a professor of marketing at concordia
university
and author of the new book the parasitic
mind
how infectious ideas are killing common
sense
god said welcome back to the reuben
report
oh my god it's so good to see you again
i wish it were
being done in person in california but
second best
i wish we were doing this in person i
know that you have a love
of southern california and the sun that
is almost
unrivaled by other human beings one time
we had you in here after you had been in
socal for a few weeks your glow the
color that you can achieve
the bronze it almost blew out our whole
system but you have a very nice tan
right now
well thank you thank you not not bad for
for up in canada so before we do
anything
i had to count beforehand and we were
trying to figure it out this is either
your seventh
or eighth appearance on the reuben
report you are now the most
returning guest of the reuben report
would you say basically in terms of
you've got
a pretty impressive cv your resume is
looking pretty good but where do where
does that fall
in the scheme i think if i only put that
on my cv i've already made it so
you're taught all right so look i wanna
i wanna obviously dive into the book
and uh you know you guys sent us the
book a couple weeks ago
and when i was reading it i kept
thinking that
what you're explaining in this book is
what about 20 of us have been
yelling about for the last five years
and a whole bunch of mainstream media
people kept saying oh this is just a
college campus thing this ain't real
you're all overstating it you're
overblowing it
uh and now it's everywhere and some of
these people have actually had mia
culpa's
you're we're seeing some people who who
used to mock us kind of go
oh maybe maybe they were kind of right
about some of this stuff so
let's try it this way for the first
question oh and i can see you're putting
your glasses on so you're ready to
be a learned professor um when did
the ideas when did did you first notice
that these bad ideas were
were creeping into society and then
we'll sort of talk about what the ideas
are
so i call them of course in the book
idea pathogens
and drawing a corollary to how animals
could be parasitized by actual brain
worms
i argue that human beings can be
parasitized by another class of
pathogens
idea pathogens so and hence this is why
it's called the parasitic mind
so i first noticed it when i was a
doctoral student at cornell
i was taking a a course with my eventual
doctoral supervisor
j edward russo who is a mathematical and
cognitive psychologist
and in the course he assigned to his
students
some post-modernist reading that was
absolutely insane now this was published
in the top the most prestigious journal
in the field journal consumer research
you know very high impact factor amongst
the social sciences
and it was complete insanity it was
basically
what is often referred to as a uh you
know
auto auto you know the guy was talking
about his consumatory experience when he
gets a warm erection
thinking about his wife and i'm thinking
this is science
uh well of course it's science because
according to these guys
post-modernism is my truth so if i share
with
with you my truth uh in a dear diary
sense it is just
as valid as quote the scientific method
and so when i was first exposed to this
post-modernism i thought it was
absolute insanity once i became a
professor i got my phd in 1994 became a
professor
i started seeing this post-modernist
thinking throughout
the halls of academia and it was usually
coupled with a rejection of biology
so biology is great in explaining the
behavior of every single species
except human beings so this was the
first instance about
28 30 years ago when i first faced the
insanity
so one of the things i i find
interesting and why i think you're such
a good
communicator about this stuff is a lot
of people think oh
these these bad ideas and identity
politics and all this stuff well this
it only is in the arts and it's only
in you know the sort of superfluous
uh you know classes and things like that
um but because you come from a science
background you've seen these things
infect virtually every level of academia
right it is in
every nook and cranny of academia a lot
of people
said exactly what you were saying well
this is just some esoteric nonsense
that a few bozos and the humanities and
the social sciences are doing
absolutely not right now most of the
granting agencies that fund
you know research in the natural
sciences in physics and chemistry and
biology and the neurosciences
will require the grant applicants
to submit a what i call a die religion
statement die
stands for diversity inclusion and
equity where you literally have to state
right up front irrespective of what
you're saying
what is it that you've done to you know
promote die
principles and what are you going to do
if you were to win the grant
in promoting thy principles now a
colleague of mine
at a fellow university here at sister
university in montreal very prestigious
university
one of my alma maters is a physical
chemist
his grant applicant he's a very very
accomplished physical chemist his grant
application was stopped
at the die statement because they felt
that it wasn't sufficiently adhering to
the die tenants
so those who think that this is just
some esoteric anomalous thing are
absolutely wrong can you go further with
that because i think a lot of people
hear that and they're like oh but the
statement means well and if that helps
more
black or trans or whatever people get
into these fields
that is somehow good but can you explain
why that is actually
antithetical to the type of research
that people like you were trying to do
look the scientific method liberates us
from the shackles of our identity that's
what makes it so wonderful
right
listening to transcendental experience
because
i don't listen to barry white thinking
that i have a certain quota
of black singers that i need to listen
to he transcends whether he's black or
white he gives me goosebumps bumps
because he's
very white so art literature music
the scientific method are the laudable
endeavors that they are precisely
because they remove those shackles of
identity
i come from a world of identity politics
as we've discussed on the show before
when i escaped lebanon so the
fundamental principle on which classical
liberalism as you well know and many of
your viewers know
is a commitment to individual dignity
when you now say
no your individual dignity must be tied
to some tribal identity i don't care how
accomplished you are
as a physicist are you a transgender
person of color and if yes we give you
the grant
what could be a greater cancer to
individual dignity it's grotesque
if you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about academia
instead of non-stop yelling check out
our academia playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics check out our full episode
playlist they're all right over here
and to get notified of all future videos
be sure to subscribe and click the
notification bell